تمت مقاطعة جلسة استماع في الكونجرس حول تطوير الطاقة والمياه
من قبل سكان القرية ،
نعم سمعت ذلك المنتصر المناسب
لذلك فور استدعائه
لطلب
بعض الصوت الغريب الذي تم إرساله من
الخلفية أولاً كان
من فيلم galaxy Quest ثم
هذا أيضًا  طلبت من اللجنة دعم
التمويل الكامل لبرنامجين مهمين
لتحفيز الطاقة الكهرمائية
داخل مكتب تقنيات الطاقة المائية التابع لوزارة الطاقة الأمريكية
وتم إنشاؤهما من خلال
قانون سياسة الطاقة لعام 2005.
أنشأ القسم 242 برنامجًا لتحفيز إنتاج الطاقة الكهرومائية
أعتقد أنه ممثل h مورجان
غريفيث
أه كما  حسنًا ، إذا تمكنا من إحضار هؤلاء
الشهود إلى الأمام ، نشكرك على
عدم تسليمك أبدًا ، الأمر يا سيدي ،
نأسف لأن هذا لم يحدث من
قبل ، لكنه عصر جديد ،
لذا امنحنا بضع لحظات ،
أعني أنها كانت لجنة لتنمية المياه ،
يمكنك ذلك  أبحر في البحار السبعة ، يمكنك أن
تضع عقلك في راحة
أه تم تشغيلها في الخلفية لمدة
20 دقيقة تقريبًا  استدعى
رئيس اللجنة الفرعية أخيرًا
العطلة القصيرة لإصلاح
الصعوبات الفنية واستؤنفت جلسة الاستماع
بدون مسار المكافأة